[Musique]
inspect vous partez en voyage on dirait
je pars en mission top secrète
embarquement
[Musique]
immédiat mais Messieurs chez Small World
Airlines tout le monde passe un bon
moment merde à la française en toute
sécurité sunny on a besoin de toi il a
eu meurtre oh je vois que tout le monde
joue les détectives on se
détend quelques instants après le
décollage un passager a trouvé la mort
et son meurtrier est encore à bord de
cet appareil il y a une assassine dans
mon avion c'est impossible je veux
apprendre à détec inspecteur Sun détec
mondialement réputé que je ne chasse
qu'un solitaire il n aurait donc pas
qu'un tueur mais de voire TR qui dit
ouais je reprends du service
il faut faire confiance à l'inspecteur
Sun c'est le meilleur oui enfin il a
surtout de la chance inspecteur Sun il
atire les ennuis comme des papier B ce
n'est pas moi qui a M bazar pas de
panique rassemblez tous les passagers ça
va à nous de jouer mon
[Musique]
équipière police stop au nom de la loi
toute la ville a failli partir en fumée
non les journalistes en font toujours
des
[Musique]
tonnes